[Music]
the spoiler clip that everybody even
Hollywood blinded by the life
that's Bonnie Tyler backed up by DNC Eve
belting out her pup masterpiece during
today's actual solar eclipse
toddler performed on a cruise ship in
the Caribbean situated to see the
Eclipse and all its glory meanwhile
Hollywood celebrated the Eclipse on
social media that's Ryan Seacrest in his
studio Dierks Bentley and a plane and
Olivia mind with her dog hi guys Sarah
Jessica Parker called herself an eclipse
chaser and Instagram this footage from a
boat in South Carolina
Lady Gaga had jokes she wrote take me to
your planet on her palms Rob Lowe and
Marcia Gay Harden were on the set of
code black and watched through a special
filter and Tony Goldwyn posted this pic
with the cast of scandal also enjoying
the moment when Paltrow Kate Hudson and
Jack Black
today's Eclipse is the first to traverse
the country coast to coast in nearly a
century as for that 80s classic well
today is shot to number one on iTunes
and Tyler said she never gets tired of
singing it fabulous for me to work with
this young gorgeous band and they did a
fabulous version of total eclipse alarm
and yeah it was really awesome yeah
[Music]